why stop smothering me hey guys welcome
to Friday re-fry diary is a look back on
my week in vlog form right now I'm in a
hotel in San Diego however my week
didn't start that way
so let's look back at all of the things
that have led me to here this week I
[Music]
stopped for a run which is like sweaty
and I'm running to catch the sunset it's
happening any minute now and this is the
slowest elevator of all time before
[Music]
three
[Music]
- good thing I get really claustrophobic
in elevators one Jesus Christ you can do
it you can do it this girl watch no you
committed do it get it Oh me am we're
going on a hike today we are business -
I know your outfit it's smooth business
on top party on the bottom kappa sure ah
debatable we are here we're going to
there
halfway there
[Music]
now it's time to go back what miles up
four miles back let's do this the
perfect meal before getting on a
six-hour flight is a spam hamburger so
we are on our way down to comic-con
Hannah Hart and I as Charles our driver
and Hannah waiting for the bathroom and
we made a pit stop to get snacks and to
relieve ourselves Funyuns
they're so fun Oh legendary how dare you
haters made it to my hotel in San Diego
which is a very historic beautiful old
hotel full of definitely at least one
ghost says numerous sources so far the
manager Kristen told Hannah a story
about a woman in the 1890s came here
maybe the early 1900s under a fake name
and ended up on the beach outside the
hotel with a gunshot in her head and now
she haunts the hotel in a friendly way
this is what happens when I'm in a place
for two days and I panic on what shoes I
should wear
[Music]
there's way too many shoes and it turns
out they put Helen I in the wrong room
so time to pack up all the things I
thought I was being so proactive about
putting up in the closet
let's move rooms we finish our first
panel eating a banana yay Comic Con okay
now we are walking to go to the Smart
Girls panel set up area to take some
photos and look at this Sports Arena
it's all very exciting we're getting
ready to go in and do it signage
hello signings yay let's walk on the
floor you can't see what I'm seeing it's
a molding make it look now now we follow
me walk
[Music]
hi look this girl's a burger look
that girl's a burger God cosplay is so
great our schedule is so packed today
that we were getting touch-ups done in
the car yay getting makeup done well
there you go guys there is a look back
at all the things that have happened
this week it's been a very busy and also
very relaxing week at the same time and
also just a really fun week too
for those of you that I got to meet at
Comic Con thanks for saying hello and
for those of you that I will meet at
VidCon in two weeks
get ready I might be smelling how was
your week let me know leave a comment
down below I hope it was well I hope at
least one tiny and/or huge amazing thing
happened to you this week that's it I
don't know
test one two my god yeah